(rocket blasting)
- This is the world's most
powerful rocket taking off.
And this is it exploding shortly after.
(crowd groaning)
After years of development,
Space X's Starship,
and its super heavy rocket
with its 33 raptor engines
finally got airborne in April,
for a short while at least.
Now, while SpaceX has launched
hundreds of spaceships,
it's Starship that the
company hopes will become
a rapidly reusable gateway into space.
But while it may have taken
years to get even to this point,
it's actually just the very
beginning of Starships long road
to carry humans to another planet.
So what's the journey ahead for Starship
and what will it take to get there?
SpaceX say the idea behind Starship
and the super heavy is to
be the first fully reusable
space transportation system
where both the spaceship
and the rocket powering it can
be used over and over again.
One of the most prominent
missions for Starship
will be to carry astronauts
from a spacecraft
orbiting the moon, down to
the lunar surface and back,
as part of NASA's Artemis
3 moon landing missions.
I caught up with WSJ space
reporter, Michah Maidenberg.
- NASA awarded a nearly
$3 billion contract
for the Artemis 3 Moon landing.
That's currently scheduled for,
you know, sometime in 2025.
2025 is coming up pretty quickly.
For SpaceX, it's a very high profile
and intense objective
that they have to reach.
- SpaceX is also planning on
using Starship to carry cargo
into space, whether that be the companys
starlink satellites or
fuel for other Starships
and SpaceX CEO, Elon Musk has also said
that one day he hopes to use
Starship for a mission to Mars.
But building something this complex
that's fully reusable isn't exactly easy.
As Musk said at WSJ's CEO council in 2021.
- Man, Starship is a hard,
hard, hard, hard project.
It is so preposterously difficult
that there are times where I wonder
whether we can actually do this.
- So what did we learn from the launch?
Well, while there have been
some tests of Starship before,
this is the first time it's been powered
by the massive super heavy
rocket system, and the company
wasn't exactly sure how
successful the launch would be.
- [Kate] If we lift off and clear the pad,
we're calling that a win.
- [George] Things seem to be going well
for the first few minutes.
Although it appeared that some of
the raptor engines were out.
The super heavy rocket
also failed to separate
from Starship, and then.
However, the launch will
have left the company
with a trove of data.
- You know, one of the
main goals of this flight
was simply to get information.
The way SpaceX historically has operated
is when it learns something,
it uses that to try to
quickly make changes,
improvements to iterate.
- So what's it going
to take to get Starship
from this to this?
Well, SpaceX will need
a lot more test flights,
as NASA's moon mission could
be as soon as two years away.
- Gwen Shotwell, the
company's longtime president
said a couple months ago at a conference,
she wants to fly a lot
of flights with Starship,
starting with the company's
own Starlink satellites
because they need to figure
out what this vehicle,
what this machine can do.
- One thing that's almost
certain is that NASA
will be watching those
flight tests closely.
The agency has said they're
not going to use Starship
to carry humans until there
have been successful tests
and that SpaceX will conduct
an uncrewed demonstration
to the moon prior to the Artemis missions.
- So in a way, right now,
one of the big next steps
for the Artemis program
is for SpaceX to show
that it can operate Starship the way
it's like laid out to do.
- So, while the launch might
have been one giant leap
for Starship, it's just
one small step for SpaceX.
(dramatic music)